The NCBI Gene database is a resource that
centralizes gene related information into
individual records.
Many different types of gene-specific data
are connected to the record including sequence
accessions, nomenclature, genomic location
and organization, publications, gene products
and their attributes, expression, interactions,
pathways, homology, variation and its phenotypic
consequences and useful links to databases
both internal and external to NCBI.
The content of Gene is derived from both automated
dataflows and curation by NCBI staff.
The starting point is typically the extraction
of gene-specific information from a publicly
available, annotated genome sequence.
The gene is assigned a category, for example
protein coding RNA, non-coding RNA, pseudogene,
ribosomal RNA or unknown based on the information
provided by each collaborating databases.
• The NCBI Reference Sequence Database or
RefSeq database, is a comprehensive, integrated,
non-redundant, well-annotated set of reference
sequences including genomic, transcript, and
protein.
Similar to a review article, a RefSeq is a
synthesis of information integrated across
multiple sources at a given time.
RefSeqs provide a foundation for uniting sequence
data with genetic and functional information.
They are generated to provide reference standards
for multiple purposes ranging from genome
annotation to reporting locations of sequence
variation in medical records.
• The Gene Reference into Function database
or GenRIF database, is a short statement about
the function of a gene.
GeneRIFs provide a simple mechanism for allowing
scientists to add to the functional annotation
of genes described in the Gene database.
Each GeneRIF has a pointer to the PubMed ID
of a scientific publication that provides
evidence for the statement made by the GeneRIF.
• The Online Mendelian Inheritance in Man
or OMIM, is a continuously updated catalog
of human genes and genetic disorders and traits,
with a particular focus on the gene-phenotype
relationship.
The following sections will help you understand
more about the NCBI gene database and how
to navigate the database to extract the information
of your interest.
The NCBI Gene database is an important resource
because it collects together in one place
information on each gene and provides links
to other NCBI and related databases.
This introduction includes a focus on links
to the PubMed database.
Access Gene by using the drop-down menu from
any of the NCBI interfaces.
Let’s look at CFTR, the gene associated
with cystic fibrosis.
At this moment, there are nearly 3060 individual
Gene records referencing CFTR, of which 353
come from humans.
Although these records are sorted by relevance
to the search term, to be certain you have
the correct genetic record, search the database
with the official symbol for your gene.
Of these 96 records, this first one is the
human gene.
Because this record is so large, note the
table of contents on the right hand side and
the additional links to related National Library
of Medicine databases and other genetic resources.
This first Summary section opens with the
official symbol and the full name of the gene
as defined in the public database of the Human
Genome Organization’s, Gene Nomenclature
Committee.
However, as you can see from the “Also known
as” list, not everyone has used that official
symbol in their publications.
This gene encodes a protein and the Summary
includes information on how that protein functions
and potential issues with gene mutations.
The RefSeq status is “reviewed”.
Thus, in this Gene record, the CFTR gene sequence
is an annotated reference sequence, curated
by NCBI staff, with unique identifiers and
serving as a baseline for medical, functional,
and comparative studies.
Genomic context describes where the gene lives.
In this case, the gene is on Chromosome 7,
the q (or long arm), in region 31.2.
For information on how chromosomes are mapped,
see the article by Clare O’Connor.
The Genome Reference Consortium submitted
the most recent assembly of the human reference
genome to GenBank in December of 2014.
Because new data and corrections have changed
CFTR’s location on the chromosome, Gene
includes information on both the current and
past assembly to assist researchers.
Note that the CFTR gene starts after the 117.4
millionth base pair on chromosome 7 in this
current assembly.
This diagram shows the direction in which
the gene is read.
Remember, the double helix can be read in
either direction and convention states the
chromosome be presented with the shorter arm
on the top or to the left.
CFTR, then, is read toward the right, but
this nearby CTTNBP2 gene is read toward the
left or the shorter arm of the chromosome.
This next section provides a type of gene
browser that offers a tremendous amount of
information.
Click on the green line representing the gene.
Now you can see information on the gene in
green, information on the transcribed messenger
RNA in blue, and information on the translated
protein in red.
Multiple blue and red lines represent splice
variants, variants which can generate different
messenger RNAs.
Experimentally verified transcripts begin
with N, while variants beginning with X represent
a predicted mRNA transcript or transcribed
protein.
Now let’s jump to a specific location on
the gene and zoom in.
Note that the larger bars represent exons
and the smaller bars are introns.
An important concept for researchers is clinical
variation, when variations in the gene have
a clinical significance.
The darker the color, the more pathogenic
or deadly the variation.
Notice that this particular variation, rs1800111,
has a PubMed citation associated with it.
Additional information in the browser includes
the gene sequence; SNPs, the Single Nucleotide
Polymorphisms, or how individuals differ from
one another; and information on the exons
and introns;all with links to related databases.
This next section, Bibliography, needs no
introduction.
These are selected PubMed citations focusing
on the human CFTR gene.
For citations on the similar genes in other
species, homologs, click on this final link.
If you need citations focusing on a specific
function of a gene, this section on GeneRIFs,
Gene References Into Function, can be very
helpful.
A single sentence is taken from the title
or abstract that concisely describes the function
or functions of the gene in that article.
These links will take you into PubMed, just
as PubMed citations can bring you back into
Gene.
There is a great deal of additional information
in the Gene record which we will cover in
future videos, including phenotypes, variation
and pathways, interactions which link to PubMed
citations discussing those interactions, protein
information, reference and related sequences,
and resource links.
I do want to highlight the Gene ontology section
which summarizes, and provides PubMed citations
for the Functions, Processes and Components
known for this gene.
Ontology is the study of what exists and gene
ontology is the controlled vocabulary of terms
describing gene product characteristics and
is compiled in the Gene Ontology Annotation
Database.
As you can see, the Gene Database provides
a one-stop node to retrieve all information
related to the gene of interest.
If you scroll down to the mRNA sequence section,
you can also access the gene sequence from
the Genbank database which primarily store
the DNA and mRNA sequence information.